a belarusian activist has been found
dead in neighboring ukraine
a day after he was reported missing
police say vitali shishoff
was found hanged in a park near his home
in the capital kiev early
on tuesday shishov laid an organization
that helps belarusians
fleeing persecution ukraine police have
launched
a murder inquiry
well for the latest i'm now joined from
kiev by dw correspondent nick connolly
nick
what more do we know so far
well uh shisha was last seen leaving his
home about 9 00 a.m
local time yesterday going out for a run
and after that though his friends
and colleagues were unable to reach him
tried to locate him based on mobile
phone data the mobile phone
location tracking was switched off and
then
this morning he was found hanged in a
park reports coming in the last few
hours in ukrainian media even that
there were signs of some kind of
confrontation that he'd
had his nose broken that these are all
unconfirmed but reports that are
circuiting here in ukraine
um all in all it's enough for the
ukrainian police to work on the
assumption that this wasn't the suicide
that this was a murder
disguised as suicide as you mentioned
there kishov was someone who
helped belarusians to leave their
country for ukraine ukraine is the
easiest place for belarusians fleeing
alexander lukashenko
to reach they don't need a visa it's
cheaper they can
communicate in russian here and it
really has become a hub for the
russian uh immigrant community well
can belarusians in exile still feel safe
well that's obviously the million-dollar
question um especially given
how much bella russian oppositional life
has now relocated to kiev whole uh
media organizations uh political experts
pundits political parties
um we asked ourselves that question when
alexander lukashenko forced that ryan
airplane
back in may to land that was actually
not heading to belarus to get that
opposition
journalist off the plane back then
people felt very safe they were
convinced that
the regime was only really looking for
people who had yet to leave the country
um that seems to be changing now for now
obviously people
connected to shishov are all pointing
the finger at the belarussian
special services they are convinced that
it is mints that's behind this
right now it's too early to say some
stories coming out here also from people
who maybe were his political opponents
in that fellow russian community here
saying there could have been potential
other motives ideological motives
um but definitely you can really see
that people are already changing their
behavior and a lot less willing
to talk to the press a lot less willing
to um give their location
when talking to the press because they
don't feel 100 safe here in kiev
nick stay with us because this leads us
to the case of the belarusian sprinter
christina zimanovskaya
the athletes have been at the center of
a political storm in tokyo she accused
belarusian officials of trying to
force her to fly home against her will
she later found refuge at the polish
embassy
her supporters say she will fly to
poland on wednesday where she's expected
to apply for asylum here's our report
christina timanovskaya had hoped to be
making headlines running for belarus in
the 200 meter dash
instead she's in the news for a
different reason
[Music]
officials attempted to forcibly deport
her back to minsk
after she criticized her coaches team
bosses blamed what they called her
emotional and psychological condition
for the decision
i'm asking the international olympic
committee for help i'm being put under
pressure to leave the country without my
consent
i'm asking the ioc to intervene in this
the attempted deportation has been
condemned by many governments
including by the german government
we have often and clearly criticized the
treatment of civil society in belarus
in recent weeks we have repeatedly seen
harassment persecution and intimidation
of independent media
and of course athletes are not immune to
this we sharply condemn this
security has been tightened around the
polish embassy in japan
diplomats have confirmed that
timonoskaya plans to fly to poland in
the coming days
joining other belarusian opposition
figures who have been forced to flee
their homeland
now back to nick connolly in kiev nick
how does this
apparent killing i have to say of an
opposition figure tie in
with this belarusian sprinter applying
for asylum in poland now
well i don't think there's any direct
connection indeed we've heard from
people around
shishov that he had been getting
increasing threats and
tip-offs about his safety in recent
weeks way before
this you know defection as it were of
christina timanovska
in tokyo but i think it shows that
almost a year now the anniversary is
next monday
of belarus's rigged election this is not
over on the one hand you know the
opposition here in
uh that has left the country by the
russian opposition that's now in kiev
and in other european cities
has not given up alexander lukashenko
hasn't been able to
silence those critics and even people
who were pretty privileged within the
belarusian system like the athletes
uh sport is a big deal in belarus
alexander luxembourg's head of the
olympic committee
so people like timothy are not willing
to keep quiet not willing to do as
they're told
and in a situation of kind of raised
tensions where
the sis belarus is coming under
sanctions under all kinds of pressure
um these kind of overreactions as with
timon oscar are going to happen more and
more and this kind of uh
unexpected outcome of something that
maybe started with a small conflict with
an olympic team
having much much bigger ramifications so
a year after those elections
this situation isn't over and alexander
luchenko isn't as comfortable
in a position of comfort and kind of
certainty as maybe he'd
hope to be bw's nick connolly
from kiev thank you nick
you